the foundation of what my human life is
based on which for me is about being a
link between the spiritual and the
physical yes and user to allow the the
spiritual to express itself in physical
and and so when my life becomes based on
that foundation it changes everything
and gives me a lot more purpose beyond
beyond the ego based purpose obviously
programmed into us by our societies and
I really resonate with the work of
people who talk about embodiment because
it's aligned with what I truly believe
we're here to do which is to brown
spiritual energies to a ground spirit in
in physical matter and to spiritual eyes
matter you know that this universe can
keep growing and become become more
self-aware and I feel like humanity has
been given a really important role by
whatever you'd like to call that source
energy normally in the book I refer to
it as the Great Spirit or you can use
God or Brahman or the universe whatever
you whatever you want to say I believe
the task we've agreed to and we've been
given by by Great Spirit is to come here
and be that link between spirit and
matter and that that to me is manifests
itself in the everyday Monday life of
human activities spiritualizing
everything we do your hand and you know
how do we how do we do that well it's a
it's a lifelong work it's a lot of work
about its it's a lot of it requires a
lot of self work I I can't start
imposing what works on me on everyone
around me thinking that this is how you
need to wake up and this is what you
need to do and you need to focus on
shadow work because I become you just
become a tyrant losing your will and so
you have to honor the fact that you're
on your own unique journey and that
everyone else is on their own unique
journey and just in in my mind put seeds
of awareness out there and some might
some of the seeds you put out there
might land on the fertile soil and helps
transform and so that's that's for me
it's that expanding of your awareness
that is the is the sign that your you're
spiritually developing and and I guess
the side effects of that are definitely
things such as feeling calm being
feeling more graceful feeling more
creative feeling more joy feeling more
grounded even when the outside world
starts become a bit tumultuous so so
shadow work is a really really
challenging and can be a very very
painful and extremely messy process like
I don't want to sort of like tiptoe
around that it can be really tough in
terms of shadow work you don't need
really need to go through life seeking
it life will constantly give you the
situations the people the events that
you need to trigger you within that may
have the potential they have the
potential to catalyze your evolution and
it's it's up to you whether you
surrender and work with those catalysts
or whether you resist them and push the
Lakers the more you resist them all
you're gonna do is send the message for
the universe I need a bigger more
powerful pattern to come my way and so
it's like do we need a little tick doing
it the universe to give us a little
tickle tickle with a feather to kind of
help us become more aware or do we need
it to give us a big hit someone's
opinion me contradict yours where's my
friend Allen it's all about your
perspective who are we in what is the
nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on super pumped
to be talking about free range humans we
have Matthew Steven joining us on the
show I'm Matt Allen thanks so much for
having me I've I've seen quite a few of
your interviews before I even make you
so I'm yeah I love the content you put
out I'm really grateful to be on the
show thank you very much and I have seen
some of your content as well and when
you release the book I sought through
Tom Montauk's tweet that he wrote the
intro for and then I soon as I started
reading it it was one of those page
turners I finished it in a day I loved
it
that link is in the bio and it's seeds
of awareness dot-com dot hey you and you
can find that the free range humans book
there you can find Matt's other book
there he was also the author of 365 days
of wholeness you find that there and I'm
so pumped to dive into this with you we
have a lot of topics here so we'll see
how well we can move between them
there's so much good stuff alright I
want to start with this question
actually we're obsessed with this
question we basically ask all of our
guests this question and the question is
what is the point of reality what's the
purpose of this reality and I feel like
we're both along the same lines here
would you say that it's the evolution of
consciousness yeah I mean obviously
that's that's quite a Dave question and
it's it took me three years to sort of
put the answer into my book so what you
just said then probably wraps up what I
believe really well I do believe this is
about evolution of consciousness and an
evolution of the universe so yeah
awesome
yeah I'm trying to see if we can kind of
gain a little bit of this like consensus
around like what the point is and have
more children kind of be born into
understanding what the point is instead
of never
ever encountering it by the time they've
died so that's that's great and well I
think I think just sorry to cut in there
I think I think it's really important
that that becomes a key question that
humanity starts asking and starts
exploring because I mean obviously
there's some things like that but it
does become a bit of a personal I guess
opinion and belief because there's some
things that you know I guess we don't we
can't ever really truly know unless
maybe we escape this human shell and
then and really find out but in terms of
you know I think our life becomes
defined by what we believe in regards to
that question and for me if if the
universe is about evolution and
evolution of consciousness then that I
guess really defines how I believe my
the foundation of what my human life is
based on which for me is about being a
link between the spiritual and the
physical yes and user to allow the the
spiritual to express itself in physical
and and so when my life becomes based on
that foundation it changes everything
and gives me a lot more purpose beyond
beyond the ego based purpose obviously
programmed into us by our societies yes
yes so well said so the more that we can
get this idea of the evolution of
consciousness being something that is
what we think is the point of the
reality the more that we can ground our
day-to-day habits actions patterns in
the process of me myself doing self work
inner engineering and be in anchoring
the divine here in the physical on earth
okay
excellent excellent so I want I want to
say this I want to see if how we how we
feel on this as well would you say that
then this this third density and this is
the physical reality of matter that we
find ourselves in and you you call this
in Bernard Gunther Tom Montag called
this the matrix control system MCs
would you say that this is a perfect
harmonic flux between good and evil
between a school and a prison to
basically be a pressure cooker for the
evolution of consciousness yeah
beautifully said I mean it's exactly how
I say it because I believe it's that
friction between those two polarities
which creates evolution and obviously
there's that human part of us as that
part of us that would love for things to
just be easy here and for things to just
settle down and go cool always go the
way we want them to in terms of the
heart bigger the bigger evolution of
consciousness and of ourselves we can't
get that we need a catalyst for that
evolution and whenever I think of this
density we're in and the way it's run
and how it operates I always think of
say a jungle let's say the Amazon jungle
if you go watch a documentary of the
Amazon jungle what you'll see there is
the the most perfect conditions for life
imaginable in terms of the temperature
in terms of the amount of rainfall and
humidity and so it's created this
container for life but then what you
also see is the most unbelievable
adaptations of life form you could ever
imagine in terms of the adaptations of
predators and then the adaptations of
prey the Lynx they've gone through to
kind of advance themselves so that they
can survive within the Amazon jungle is
just unbelievable you don't see life
forms like that really anywhere else on
the planet and it's because of the
pressure it's because of the constant
friction between that those predators
and between those preys that creates
those adaptations in the plant life in
the insect life in the animal life and
so I believe it's the same here we we
choose to come down into this density
and experience this intense friction
which which manifest as these evil
forces as this control system which is
constantly testing us challenging us
prodding every weak point that we have
within ourselves and I believe there's a
high purpose to that which is which is
the hell
us to grow which is to separate the I
guess you could say the spiritually
strong from the the spiritually maybe
not ready you know not ready in this
life to form so sort of advanced aware
whether were there heading and so yeah
it's it's I think it is both both a
prison and a school I really like how
you also talked about that that pressure
cooker friction for nonhumans as well
for even animals and plants that also
experience the predator-prey
relationship that's constantly force a
forcing function for evolution super
interesting and ok I want to focus on
this too we talked about this just a
moment ago that Sri Aurobindo someone
that we both admire a lot says that we
are in need of the the grounding of
unity consciousness in the physical
world to create the life divine on earth
and this is like an idea is like this
range of human development and Ken
Wilber has talked about this as well
with integral theory and Jean Piaget was
talking about this as well Alison Gopnik
stalking about this with the very very
early child base um basically that you
you if why don't we talk you know we're
talking about every child knowing well
what about every child knowing that
there's this range of human development
and you want to get to a point where you
know what unity consciousness is and you
want to get to a point where you ground
that in the physical and manifest that
in your families and your friends and of
your everyday interactions so how do you
how do you think about that range of
human development yeah I mean what by
the way I just love how we've dealt
straight into the deep stuff this is the
stuff I love chatting about
I mean yeah as he as you said earlier I
think I might have been off-camera me
may be said in the intro that we've been
influenced by similar people in Bernard
Gunther and Tom Montauk and they've
obviously been heavily influenced by
people actually or have been do and the
reason I really like their work so much
is because I feel like they focus on
aspects of spiritual development and
human development that I feel a lot of
other spiritual movements or practices
are missing which is embodiment and
which was exactly what you said which is
grounding spiritual energies into
physical matter and I another person who
I've recently got into I'm not sure if
you've got into her work a lady called
Marion Woodman who is all about
embodiment fifi was a call young analyst
okay she thought she talks a lot about
embodiment and the shadow she passed
away not too long ago but her work is
just phenomenal and I really resonate
with the work of people who talk about
embodiment because it's it's aligned
with what I truly believe we're here to
do which is to ground spiritual energies
to ground spirit in in physical matter
and to spiritualize matter you know that
this universe can keep growing and
become become more self-aware and I feel
like humanity has been given a really
important role by whatever you'd like to
call that source energy I'm normally in
the book I refer to it as the great
spirit or you can use God or Brahman or
the universe whatever you whatever you
want to say I believe the task we've
agreed to and we've been given by by
great spirit is to come here and be that
link between spirit and matter and that
that to me is manifests itself in the
everyday Monday life of human activities
spiritualizing everything we do and and
you know how do we how do we do that
well it's a it's a lifelong work it's a
lot of work about it's it's a lot of it
requires a lot of self work and that's
that's why I am that's why I really
resonate with
bernard gunther and marion Woodman and
sri aurobindo because they're honest in
that clearing the vessel of all out
formers of integrating our shadow embody
embodying our spirit it is a lot of work
it really is and so i guess that were a
differs from some spiritual teachings
like the new age where it's all about
it's all about ascension and going
higher and it's nearly about denying the
body and and some some religions of even
I guess pushed abusing the body you know
self self abuse and flagellation and and
it's and it's been taught in human
societies for a long time that the body
is sinful that the body is gross and
we're and we and we erase in our
societies with being taught a lot of
shame about who we are and our bodies
and I believe that's part of the agenda
of the matrix control system to keep
spirit disconnected from matter so that
spirit the spiritual part of ourselves
can be continuously fed on by higher
higher predatory beings and so yeah I
guess to come back to that key point
grounding of those spiritual energies
and embodiment is is what I believe
we're here to do and in terms of how to
do that and how that looks on a day to
day basis well that's that's a you know
that's a that's a lot of it's a long
conversation yeah I'm super happy that
you brought up this embodiment so what
as you basically get it's funny because
it actually brings us even to like Isaac
Newton and the and we can talk about
this third law of of classical mechanics
with of motion where you talk about
every action having an equal opposite
reaction and the sri aurobindo says that
as you go up you equally go down so you
go down to the depths of hell you to go
up to the heavens and it has to be like
this process so funny
how science and spirit are now becoming
more and more talking about the same
things and you brought this up in free
range humans as well the idea of the
quantum theory being such a mind-blowing
explosion of scientific advancement now
where we've where we realize that the
whole idea of what is a multiverse and
what is a many-worlds and what is all
that is and what is so similar to the
dow god brahman source it's so
interesting how these things can can be
portrayed as similar now as well so it's
it's it's the more that we kind of
figure out where things like like a
Newton's third law of motion can
actually work with the spiritual
understanding or where the quantum
theory can work with what is God Brahman
or Dow I think that that understanding
of of also the not only the human um the
individual human developmental process
but also the collective developmental
process is just that that's gonna be
extremely helpful and I really
appreciated how you brought both science
and spirituality in and I think that's
gonna be one of the big differentiating
factors for artists authors scientists
spiritual leaders is their ability to
synthesize those two yeah moving forward
it's it's it's it's a yin and yang of
the of the big of the big picture I
think that there is a buffet of union of
possibilities for people in the sense
that yes this idea of embodying your
process of spiritual self work into the
physical world and kind of basically in
a sense you become blissed-out joyful
peaceful calm in constant harmony with
your masculine and feminine you have so
many of these other ones that that you
brought up the shadow work and shadow
integration
connection to the wholeness of reality
that to me the idea is that it's a
buffet of options as though people can
take whatever path they want up this
this big mountain do you see it as well
like this big buffet of options that
people can explore what works the best
for their own process of of spiritual
self work and embodiment do you feel
similarly about that yeah absolutely I
mean in terms of what we're what we're
talking about here like embodiment and
shadow work there's a lot of different
modalities out there and practices that
I guess reach the same sort of outcomes
and talk about the same sort of things
with just with different titles and
different languages and these are just
the terms that resonate with us and I
think I really like how Krishnamurti
talks about how truth is a pathless
what's the query use do you remember
that one truth is a pathless truth I've
totally forgotten the I think I think
I'm aware let me let me see where you
find it birth is a pathless land I think
I think that's what I'm talking about
anyway pathless land I don't know I
don't know if that's great but he's
talking about how there's no one system
that can work for everyone and I real
that's what it is
it's so good that's a good one did I get
did I get us land a dialogue with Jake
wood Jenny Krishnamurthy yep yeah okay
cool this summer's it didn't sound right
coming out but it was so I really
resonate with what he what he says
because I believe that we're all being
guided in our own way by our homes
higher spirit in a way that works for us
and when I when I think about my path to
awakening and all the experiences I went
through and the challenges and the
suffering that I had to go through that
was that was so unique to me and it was
so specific to what I needed and I look
back at that I'm like there's definitely
something guiding me through that
process there's something that that
guided me through
process but also every time I was broken
down and thought I wasn't gonna make it
something appeared some some bit of
someone or a piece of information or
something appeared that was exactly what
I needed in that moment and I can see
now that those synchronicities were
guiding me and that they were there
guiding you and they're guiding everyone
else in their own unique way and and so
that for me when I when I think about
that that's why I called my website and
blog seeds of awareness because I
realized I I can't start imposing what
worked on me on everyone around me
thinking that this is how you need to
wake up and this is what you need to do
and you need to focus on shadow work
because I become you just become a
tyrant losing your will and so you have
to honor the fact that you're on your
own unique journey and that everyone
else is on their own unique journey and
and just in in my mind put seeds of
awareness out there and some might some
of the seeds you put out there might
land on a fertile soil and help someone
transform and some might take quite a
while to they might be dormant for quite
a while within someone's mind before
they actually grow and so I think that
in terms of what you're talking before
about that personal evolution that we're
going through for me I'm the higher or
the the more I've evolved it's all been
based around integration of the fellow
the more I've become self-aware of my my
blinds what's and had the codes to sit
with and confront my programming my
wounds my traumas and to actually face
those things that terrify me the most
the more I've done that the more I've
realized that there are hidden energies
within those dark places within me that
I'm afraid to go and those energies when
you begin unlocking them all sudden this
this energy for daily life and this
passion and this creative energy starts
flowing out of you
and all of a sudden as you clear your
vessel of its of its of your shadow and
more spiritual energy start anchoring
into you your awareness does really
start to expand and I believe what I say
in the book is that we have the
potential to access that universal mind
that universal consciousness whilst
we're in physical matter and and apply
that universal consciousness to our
mundane everyday life our relationships
our jobs and what we do and and and we
do the work of spirit that way but and
so that's that's for me it's that
expanding of your awareness that is the
is the sign that your you're spiritually
developing and and I guess the side
effects of that are definitely things
such as feeling karma being feeling more
graceful feeling more creative feeling
more joy feeling more grounded even when
the outside world starts to become a bit
tumultuous so so shadow work is a really
really challenging and can be a very
very painful and extremely messy process
like I don't want to sort of like tiptoe
around that I can be really tough and
and and it's difficult to find a
container in our lives where we can
actually nurture ourselves and gives us
our space to do that because this world
were in apart from right now and this
lockdown it generally demands that we
live at such a fast pace such a hectic
lifestyle that very few people feel like
they can slow down and actually work on
themselves but when we do give us that
space it can be very messy but on the
other side of that coin the growth that
we get from that is so worth it in my
opinion yeah
it's crucial the economic machineries
just gorgeous all the time running and
so to take the time to work on ourselves
in all of these like you said seeds of
awareness there's all these different
past this big buffet of options for
people to explore we use something that
doesn't appear no said on our show as
well as that you do have to drill down
to water dig down to water because
that's this idea of sampling you can we
can get caught up in just sanity yes yes
I love that one and so basically yeah
picking whatever works but another
critical part is that um the whole idea
of if I could only fix that outside of
me then I'll be happy and it's now
becoming more and more frequent that
spiritual leaders are saying that we're
overly obsessed with just saying that
it's just this thing it's my spouse it's
my job it's my it's the country that I'm
in in the politics it's all outside let
me fix that thing outside and yeah yeah
versus the idea of doing the actual um
inner engineering and one of the big
things that comes up and you brought
this up you even had to go through a
definition of it in your book which I
think's still extremely important the
idea of cognitive dissonance is such a
prevalent thing that occurs anytime that
were presented with new information that
doesn't fit into our worldview or
cognitive schema were immediately trying
to emotionally stressful II respond to
decline that new information versus if
we took the time to be like you know why
is Matt currently telling me that he
thinks you know this specific thing
about about me Alan you know you've been
telling me you've only been sleeping six
hours you haven't been working out or
you've been eating not so healthy and so
you're basically helping me get work
you're feeding me that information from
a new perspective that helps me go
through the process of actually becoming
healthier and it's a crucial thing to be
able to do is to to navigate the
landscape of new information coming at
you don't have cognitive dissonance be
receptive towards what people are saying
and potentially find new ways for you to
pursue that your own your own evolution
you litt you actually go through this in
the book too you give a massive list of
health detoxifying from negative forces
shattering the problem reaction solution
limbic fear-based trauma conditioning
and that's making us more susceptible to
disease and stress embarking on quest
artistically express our unique gifts
eating well fasting sleeping well
exercising stretching moving our bodies
unsubscribing from alcohol drugs big
pharma the legacy archaic media
enterprise lame I created a new acronym
for it I will no longer be calling it
mainstream media mainstream media is now
this this is what MSM is now in my
opinion is all these independent content
creators and lame the legacy archaic
media enterprise is like that is so
you're you're you you gave all these
ideas about health it's a paramount um
aspect of of our moment-to-moment life
and I really appreciate how you went
through that in you went through it in
great detail about toxicity and even
germ theory you you really took it to
the next level like yo like you being in
peak health basically makes you hella
immune yeah absolutely
yeah you did you want me to elaborate on
that elaborate on it for us yeah yeah I
mean how when I first started awakening
I mean in my in my feels like a past
life but for in my 20s I was a
professional athlete here in Australia
and whilst I was I was fit I definitely
wasn't very healthy and one of the first
things when I awakened was realizing
that I really need to cleanse the
physical vessel that I'm in because
whilst I'm whilst I'm addicted I had a
very long term sleeping pill addiction I
used to take a lot of pharmaceutical
drugs for pain and injuries that I used
to get and anti-inflammatories been
shrinking on alcohol
no party drugs just this processed foods
and a lot of toxicity builds up in the
body which I explained in the book is I
believe is the actual foundation of the
development of disease and that's going
into that theory is probably two to
three much detail to go into right now
but I outline it in detail in the book
and so I guess the first for me the
first step was was cleansing the vessel
and but I also started realizing that -
there's there's different ways to change
our habits we can we can willfully try
and change our habits which was
generally the way our society fire us
through people in our society try to
improve themselves which I believe is
coming more from that kind of masculine
point of view those those that that
masculine part of ourselves which is
very willful so we try to change
ourselves through discipline through
applying disciplined habits and stuff
like that and I think there's there's a
place for that but I think it can only
we can only sustain it for so long and
so I started realizing that if if I want
to change these habits within myself and
and actually bring myself to a place of
health and wholeness I need to look to
the deepest source of as to why these
habits have actually came about and for
me that's all the things that you know
the book the book goes into which is
understanding the programming we're all
subjected to growing up both the
programming within our families we grow
up and we become a product of our our
family environment in our social
environment but then before we can even
think for ourselves were sent through
the education system and we're also
bombarded by this relentless amount of
subliminal mind programming from the the
lamestream media and from from from big
pork from big corporations you have a
lot of a lot of big corporations
specifically socially junk-food Giants
target children because they want to
they want to create customers for life
so they they advertise they target their
marketing towards children which is
which is really insidious
and then and then also a lot of our
habits where we do them whether it be
through binge drinking or addictions or
whether it be through overeating or even
you know under eating like like things
like anorexia it's often to compensate
for deep inner wounds that are in our
shadow that we're not acknowledging and
what those wounds are for each person is
so unique it could be it could be
growing up in a fragmented family where
there wasn't enough emotional and
physical affection and love or it could
be outright physical or emotional abuse
or it could be just being things like
being bullied at school or the amount of
I guess performer we can experience
growing up specially when we're children
and we're so sensitive is it's so
widespread and only only we can sort of
explore what we've personally gone
through and probably in past lives as
well and and that would I that's what I
believe is the true source of a lot of
these issues that we see manifest
outwardly and so when I started trying
to change my habits in my everyday life
for quite a few years it was it was
through the Tony Robbins methods and
affirmations and and and trying to
willfully discipline myself and it
wasn't until years of that just not
working for any lengthy period of time
did I realize oh my god I need to get to
the source of where my issues are coming
from which would for me or most of my
issues dated back to the first 10 to 15
years of my life and failed hood and I'm
still working through a lot of them and
the other thing that really helped me
was my relationship with my current wife
I think I think relationships are an
incredible way to do shadow work because
I think there's only so much we can do
in our own because as self-aware and as
introspective as we want to be we we
difficult it's difficult you need doing
yeah exactly great yeah
because it's it's so difficult to be
objective when we're analyzing ourselves
and
trying to understand ourselves so when
someone else comes along especially in
an intimate relationship when we
inevitably start triggering each other
in that relationship and and this can
happen in friendships as well but it
definitely happens more intensely in
romantic relationships and so when I met
my wife
we actually remarkably had so many of
the same issues we both had addiction to
sleeping pills she had experience
without going into all them we had quite
a few of the same issues and we started
triggering each other a lot and we and
we're both pretty fiery we started
challenging each other a lot and that we
started realizing that where we were
triggering each other was where the work
was actually yup with our work was
needed and in relationships it can go
either way you can you can figure each
other and it turns into explosive
finding and you hate each other forever
or you can both take a pause and realize
that what you're what you're probably
doing is shattered projecting on each
other and if we actually sit down and
take a breath and take responsibility
for our triggers in our shadow
you know the relationship can lead to
incredible growth and so sandy like
called it a trigger surfing and yeah
your skill to to get accustomed to is
that specific thing when you have that
experience with someone that's close to
you in that relationship yeah navigate
that calmly skills yeah and and and see
where that takes you yeah huge yeah
absolutely absolutely and I'm I'm so
grateful for the awareness my wife has
brought to me about myself and we've
been together nearly seven years and I
would say for the first four or five
years see I was very resistant through
what she was trying to help me see
within myself
very very stubborn and but eventually
you know and because because we you know
had so much love for each other and
through her patience and constant
support in helping me become
or aware of myself she helped me grow in
so many areas that without that
relationship I know for a fact I never
would have actually I never would have
fully grown in those areas and I've got
to still got a long way to go I want to
I don't want to make it sound like I'm
mum but the difference is the difference
is fully now and I'm sort of like in
more of a state of humility where I'm
aware I've got a long way to go and I'm
very receptive to being thrown more
about myself whenever I can whereas back
then it was it was I was very resistant
to it so the more we considered process
and relationships aren't you know
relationships aren't the only like the
only way to grow but once again going
back to that theme earlier in this
interview they're their catalyst
whenever we get whenever we get involved
in anything that creates that friction
it can be a catalyst for incredible
growth so I really believe in terms of
Fator work you don't need really need to
go through life seeking it life will
constantly give you the situations the
people the events that you need to
trigger you within that they have the
potential they have the potential to
catalyze your evolution and it's it's up
to you whether you surrender and work
with those catalysts or whether you
resist them and push them away curse
them already resist them all you're
gonna do is send the message for the
universe I need a bigger more powerful
pattern to come my way and so it's like
do we need a little tea do we need the
universe to give us a little tickle
tickle with a feather to kind of help us
become more aware or do we need it to
give us a big hit over the head with a
sledgehammer that's that's what I
believe is the individual choice yes I
so so so strongly said okay so a crucial
aspect to all these different people
that we've been mentioning and you
talked about this in the book quite a
bit as well is the focus on childhood
and that the more of a of a healthy
upbringing that we have the more it's
it's it's good more conducive for us to
unleash our full gifts itself into the
world but but also
we have basically these instances in our
lives which we could call like
cornerstones let's say in our lives
whether it be at age 2 or age 6 or age
12 or age whatever 18 and we have these
instances that are called the
cornerstones that pretty much a lot of
our world view is kind of built up on
top of these ok
and now what what we can do is when
we're presented later in our lives with
like you said either the little tickle
of a feather or the big hammer like
later on if you don't respond to the
tickle of the feather that usually what
that's trying to do is it's trying to
tickle at one of those cornerstones and
and so if we can recognize that that
this is here to serve me and to help me
evolve and that the more that I practice
like you said clearing your vessel you
had so many instances of clearance for
yourself to become a healthier happier
more holistic person wrote a whole book
on that and that all of us have all of
these aspects to our lives that if we if
we clear the vessel it makes it easier
for us to recognize the little tickle of
the feather yes I want to talk about the
Utah cross and book I love this a lot
the worldwide theatrical drama and a lot
of it is promulgated by the lamestream
media that there is an enemy this
mockolate Machiavellian divide and
conquer and it's not just happening for
and geopolitically but it's happening
here domestically left versus right in
the US and that we basically so many
people in this like intellectual dark
web and whatnot basically talk about it
like being a fiddler on an a-frame roof
that you you you stay right on the
center of deep
nuance and you don't slip down to either
one of these extreme sides and that the
more you can kind of straddle that the
better um I have friends now across
different countries in the world China
Saudi Arabia Russia Iran just tons of
different countries they don't believe
this the things that they're taught
about the u.s. being their enemy either
I think that's very important you
brought you brought that up to that it's
it's equally important that people
around the world don't believe what
they're in doctrine indoctrination
lamestream media is trying to push that
there are all these enemies around the
world yeah expand on that for us yeah
well I mean in the book I talk at length
about what researchers call the matrix
control system and one of the main goals
of this matrix control system is to keep
us in constant division and conflict and
there's different levels of reasons as
to why that is on the basic kind of like
3d level here in terms of like the the
global elite of the finance here is
those those who have gained an
incredible amount of centralized power
over this world particularly over the
last hundred years those who run the
basically control the economic system
through the Federal Reserve banks have
have immense power and and it's they
clearly have an agenda for where they
want to take the world and they're such
a tiny percentage of people in terms of
comparing with the with the billions of
people around the planet that the only
way they can control us is through
dividing us and and so they they subject
us through an endless array of of
socially social engineering techniques
what you said before which is the the
Machiavellian technique which was coined
by a dictator from Italy or somewhere
like that back back a few hundred years
ago called Nicolo Machiavelli and he he
talked about how dictate
and people back then could control both
sides of a debate and and basically
deliberately cause friction so that the
the public come to conflict and then
they can acts like the benevolent third
party who has to come in with control
systems and and laws and regulations to
keep to keep the piece in order and you
can see that anyone being both sides of
the conflict yeah fun fun on both sides
they love the conflict so we can see
that that happens still to this day but
even on a more intense level so you look
at this world and you see where the
vibra on every level possible and
there's constant issues coming up that
creating more conflict whether it be to
do with you know on a global level like
there's climate change or there's
vaccines or there's you know the
feminist movement or there's the
transgender movement or there's I'm
forgetting quite a few but there's
endless things that I really you would
call them trigger topics they're
constantly through their use of the
lamestream media this global elite
constantly putting these topics out into
the public that they know get people
emotionally rolled up and emotionally
heated up and they they create these
through different opinions around them
and they they manipulate you they
manipulate you to side with it with with
a certain opinion and then to fight with
everyone else especially on social media
they love us getting into conflict on
social media and they do it with
politics especially with the left and
right and it's all it's all theatre it's
all the game it's all it's all a load of
absolute crap and and on the basic third
density agenda we we have to wake up to
that manipulation if we're going to free
ourselves from this control system
because as long as we're staying divided
then we lose all our power because it's
only in unity it's only through
connectedness and we are all connected
on the deepest level anyway that we that
we can that we can have the power to
overcome these systems we're in and they
do it also with the generational gaps
I love turning the baby-boomers on to
the Millennials and the other way around
it was trying to turn men against women
and women against men
there's religions against each other
religions yeah different there are so
many examples of divisions in this world
it is just insane and even as you grow
up it begins when we grow up we were
taught we're divided into classrooms
were divided into different schools were
divided into different states and we're
and all these different divisions are
given identities and you're manipulated
to identify with them and in to feel
that whoever identifies with something
else is your enemy and so that is the
that is probably the cornerstone of what
this dividing of what this control
system gets its power from and and then
but then on a higher level it's my
opinion that there there are also hidden
forces that before you get there let me
let me get let me because you're about
to get I want to give the preface to
where you're about to go yeah there's
the on a too quick right before that the
there's this idea of inclusive stake
holding versus self dealing the and that
very closely resonates and that's prop
promulgated right now by Joon Yoon and
the UN Family Foundation it's an
excellent fact how inclusive stake
holding that
service to other versus service to self
sto vs. STS and the general idea is that
the more that you become in this state
of unity consciousness the more you
spend time in the service to other
mentality and the self-dealing idea is
that you're gonna be spending more time
trying to service to your own self
and that the more that our social fabric
is designed and architected around
trying to get more children and adults
to understand the inclusiveness the
interconnectedness of all beings then we
can more easily get to the service to
others now you give this okay you have
two acronyms that you use here one is
nhf negative hostile forces and Bernard
and Tom use these as well and os which
is a cult entities you said that these
negative forces work through
approximately four to six percent of the
population which are psychopathic people
and that can file under this idea of a
cabal or a cult and that this is an idea
of puppeting multinational corporate
monopolies using Edward Bernays style
tactics of sculpting the perspective of
the masses there's this incredible clip
with them from my dinner with Andre the
movie where they also talk about the
traumatized Stockholm Syndrome
population that decides to defend the
own prison that they've built and so
elaborate on um the the higher
dimensional forces channeling through
these organic portals of people and yeah
yeah so I mean yeah this is these are
the sort of topics that can consume sort
of a bit out there for some people and a
bit more like a sci-fi movie or
something like that but it's my my
belief my experiences and researchers
researchers led me to the belief that
the
the people that basically orchestrate an
engineer this institutionalized control
system wherein which concludes you know
the government and military and economic
systems and all those sort of things I
personally believe that they themselves
are not on top of the hierarchy the
control system hierarchy and they're
either directly controlled or and
complete puppets - hidden non-physical
forces that basically see themselves as
the owners and controllers of humanity
kind of like how a farmer would see
himself as the owner of his livestock
and that they don't whilst the
Psychopaths they use as their puppets on
earth have their own agenda which is
generally around power and control and
complete narcissism and and getting
actual pleasure out of this being
sadistic and controlling and
traumatizing others I believe that these
higher predatory forces are basically
doing this as running this control
system as a farming operation in order
to generate a certain energy that they
feed off and it goes back to that what
we're talking before about the analogy I
was using earlier about the jungle howl
and all life is is evolved by that
friction between predator and prey and
that occurs on every level you see here
on the on the in the physical world
whether it be the microscopic world
there's predator prey the insect world
there's predator prey the animal world
predator prey the bird world predator
prey but when you start realizing that
our physical world is such a tiny
bandwidth in terms in terms of what
reality actually is and our physical
senses that we perceive the world
through in these human bodies are so
extremely limited in terms of what
actually the frequencies that are out
there so much more on the
electromagnetic spectrum beyond just a
visible light and so much more um
clairvoyance and extrasensory perception
that exists outside the five senses
absolutely and I and I personally
believe that as part of our as part of
this farming operation our our senses
been limited somewhat in terms of our
psychic senses and what were able to
perceive and so through probably most
likely through genetic modifications
over quite a long period of time and so
in terms of outside this physical realm
we start heading into the astral and
spiritual realms and I believe that
there's still that predator-prey element
that still exists there and that there
are predatory non-physical forces that
have cut themselves off from the divine
source which is where we all get our
energy from and so just as there are
higher positive forces there are higher
negative forces and basically they they
need to manipulate other beings to
manipulate their energy out of them to
sustain themselves because as I said
they've cut themselves off from that
original original source of energy they
they're basically taking a complete
service to self path and and frozen the
path of evolution towards ultimate I
guess you could call it evil or darkness
and so that's what I believe we start
coming to the ultimate kind of I guess
foundation of what what this planet has
been turned into with a lot of esoteric
traditions with the movies like The
Matrix were referring to have all been
talking about for a very long time but
again I believe that those forces are
actually a necessary part of the fabric
of this reality and necessary to be here
like they're not I don't believe they're
out of place I don't believe that yeah
yeah they provide a smoothness to the
evolution exactly exactly I believe that
in terms of the universe growing and
evolving and in terms of Earth growing
involving and us being links with
transducers between the spiritual in the
physical world and embodying embodying
spiritual energies I don't think that
evolution would occur without those
predatory forces catalyzing put
constantly challenging us to grow and
evolve but those predatory forces are
also
they're also they've been given their
own free will
that so the harm and damage they can do
is very real and there's always a chance
that the the experiment that I believe
the diviners has has created in terms of
humanity being that highest link between
the spiritual and physical there is a
chance that it may not succeed and that
the the Great Spirit may have to start
again and possibly it's it's tried a few
times here on earth and hasn't hasn't
fully succeeded and has to press the
reset button and the more we identify
with the spiritual like in our physical
bodies that can be terrifying that can
be extremely confronting because whilst
we're in the physical with the human
instincts and the cellular instinctive
primitive desire to survive and keep
procreating that can be terrifying but
the more we identify with the spiritual
part of ourselves the more we can come
to acceptance of that and and realize
that all we can do is give it our best
shot all we can do is is is through the
best we can to be in service of of at
what we believe our purpose is here and
there's a lot of things actually out of
our control that we can only surrender
to and have faith in and and I believe
when we do that it can take away a lot
of fear the more we identify with that
spiritual part of ourselves the more we
can willing to confront and overcome the
fear of death but when we realize that
we're actually being fed upon by these
higher non-physical entities we can
start studying and realizing how they're
doing it we can study and realize how
they're actually getting this energy out
of us and we can work on practical
things day to day to stop that being
siphoned from us and that energy then
rather than feeding them it gets
transmuted back into your own purpose in
your own spiritual path through your
creative output and your energy you
you've all the sudden got more energy to
give to life because it's not being
siphoned away from you've got more
energy to give to your creative passions
to your family to your work to your self
work and that's why that's why I think
it's important to discuss and
this is so that we can protect ourselves
from it and pursue what we're here for
you that's why you give this title to
you yeah you give this title of free
range humans you say that you know life
feeds on life just like we have our own
little chickens and pigs and cows that
we have under the under the impression
that they are free to roam and range and
then eventually to slaughter and
similarly humans getting this impression
that we are free to roam and range but
why does 50% of our waking hours go to
work that we don't even love doing for
money to impress people we don't even
like that whole idea and then the and
then the like you said if we're
constantly bombarded with fear and
trauma based programming we agreed that
lifeforce energy right just like you
went to a chicken you don't want your
chicken to get extremely stressed and
eat it just like you don't want you
don't want to your human to be so so
stressed so you let them have the idea
of free-range and then so I really I
really appreciated that style of
thinking and if and just if people
realize the life feeds on life idea it's
like humans not being at the top of the
food chain is actually like cosmically
um beyond what is present in our limited
perceptive 3-dimensional reality it
becomes more and more something that we
should probe at with science and explore
that spiritually and scientifically
because otherwise we have so much hubris
and we just believe that we're at the
top we're at the dam or so awesome
humans and you you also went as far as I
think this is an important thing to
bring up on on just a trajectory basis
um you know we talked about the
beginning you know what is the point but
also how did the
I'll even start because a lot of what
we're made to believe is that it's 13.8
billion years old four and a half
billion years ago the earth is formed we
had this massive Cambrian explosion that
happened a couple hundred million years
ago after you know dinosaurs were
absolutely going to roam the planet
until finally asteroid came wiped - 66
million years ago which is what gave
room for the human to end up evolving
from you gave even this very interesting
scientific example which I'd never heard
of that at that about 6 million years
ago or so mark that there was a very
serious fusion that the that the
chimpanzee the monkey has a 48
chromosomes and we wonder why do we have
46 and it's because they're 2a and 2b
merged into r2 and I thought that was a
very interesting there was another
protein that you mentioned in there and
I just thought that was very interesting
the idea of intelligent design is so
easily just discredited but I think it's
still important we can scientifically
understand better and better and those
two realities can can coexist yeah
thinking and then like what is the you
know there's so many people that talk
about this whole egg yolk this whole big
chess game you know that idea of you
know the humans and you and we went into
ancient Sumerian culture as well and how
they had talked about being a gold and
other lifeforce energies being mined
there's very interesting things that you
piece together I thought yeah yeah yeah
I mean these are just the topics that I
love exploring because I find the more
that I delve into the nature of this
reality and who we are and what this
world is that we're living in the more
the more I sort of understand the more I
understand the more I can sort of work
towards actually like solutions for
freeing ourselves and the the problem
with a lot of people is that a lot of
these topics and a lot of these areas
are very confronting and they don't want
to look into it they want us to keep
living in their little naive bubble and
go
through life with a very small range of
perceptions and that can kind of like
you know that whole that phrase
ignorance is bliss can give us this
little naive bubble of bliss but it also
leaves us extremely vulnerable and and
because naivety leaves us very
vulnerable and exposed to manipulate
being manipulated and I think we it's
crucial for Humanity to overcome that
manipulation and that's why in the book
I I really try to be as open and upfront
about confronting the the the idea that
we're actually as you said we're not on
top of the food Fame we're not this apex
species that we've been told that we've
been told we are we're not in this
incredible safe and secure system and
world that a lot of people have been
told that they're in and that the faster
we can confront that and realize the
incredible manipulation that has been
done to us and that we're actually being
fed upon whilst as I said it's very
confronting and very terrifying the
farther the faster we can the more we
can confront that the more the spell
that's been put over us can start the
break and we can start to actually
access the true part of ourselves
and dive into you know access that part
of ourselves that on the that's on the
other side of the shadow in there and
the things that we're that terrify us to
confront and in terms of what you're
talking about before it's you know I
love exploring our ancient history
because there's so many pieces of the
puzzle that are a part of that and in
particular looking at our DNA I I
believe as I explained in the book and
as you said before that there's a lot of
evidence that our DNA has been tampered
with and the genetic modifications have
actually taken place and in particular
the merging of the chromosome to a and
through B which have been merged
together as you said in in chromosome
and human chromosome number two and it's
human chromosome number two that gives
us this incredible ability to think like
we do this intellect that we have the
really does separate us from all other
animal life on this planet and but it's
how chromosome true came about which is
really really interesting because for it
to have happened by chance for the for
the chromosome 2a and 2b which are
present in chimpanzees to have merged
together like they do in humans it it's
just the probability is just so
ridiculous it probably wouldn't have
happened in millions or billions of
years and and the way it happened so
perfectly really points to some
intentionality behind it and then
there's our ability to talk no other no
other animal species on this planet can
talk like we do and we're told it's just
been part of our natural evolution but
we we really haven't been here that long
for unbelievable adaptations and
advancements like that to happen and
it's our fox p2 protein that has also
undergone crazy adjustments for us to be
able to communicate like you and I right
right now that this really worth looking
more into there's there's enough
anomalies there there's enough craziness
about that that we gotta go well there's
this is worth us exploring more in using
the brilliance of science to find
answers for many which many people are
doing outside the mainstream and the
Cambrian explosion is another one of
those moments that science is trying to
be like how did that massive explosion
of life happen in such a short period of
time yeah there's there's no all the
like Graham Hancock some aspirations
into archeology yeah because there's so
many things like go Blakeley Tepe that's
at least shattering our perceptions of
who we were even just even 12,000 years
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely and so
for me when I look into all this stuff
it just constantly keeps pointing back
to the same thing that there is there is
something manipulating us there's
something controlling us and there's
something that doesn't want us to know
who we are and our history and where we
came
from it wants to keep us in a very
limited range of perception and it wants
to keep us extremely ignorant so that we
can be continuously manipulated and
exploited and as I keep coming back to
the same point it's it's very
confronting to to face that and face
that possibility because we've been so
utterly programmed into this illusion of
freedom and into this illusion that
we're living in this safe and secure
world that we can trust trust the
leaders around us and trust these
systems around us and to have that
illusion broken is is utterly terrifying
for most people but I don't know if it's
just me that's looking at on people
becoming a hardcore on breaking free of
the matrix control system right now I
don't know if it's just me but it feels
like given the Jeffrey Epstein and what
happened in the end of 2019 and given
the coronavirus and given kind of some
of like the this whole I'd this whole
meeting it's now becoming public with
like Davos is now meeting publicly or
you know now it's still privately but
now it's not necessarily like you know
Bilderberger trilateral commission but
now it's like oh yeah we meet every year
anyway so there's a lot of things where
people like James O'Keefe and Alex Jones
are not kind of like going in to get
these pieces of content um that share
with people so I feel like there's this
big like movement towards what you're
talking about regarding people waking up
to that make sure the control system
yeah yeah absolutely and and it's I
think what's happening is that where all
the esoteric traditions and even
religions have talked about this time of
transition this point that we're heading
towards where you could basically call
it our last cancel opportunity to become
as a species of humanity to become that
link between the spirit of the world of
spirit and matter before there's
possibly another reset or a new sort of
experimental okay attempted it is done I
want to ask I want to ask you this
question
you think that the the the the New World
Order totalitarian AI tip toe that's
kind of happening with brain computer
interfaces 500 technologies genetic
engineering all these types of things
this could be one of those bottlenecks
or like Fermi filters or resets as
people call in the evolution of
consciousness where if we're not which
could have happened in the past as well
where we're not spiritually or morally
or ethically advanced enough and then we
have these oshit moments so so um I
wanna I want to play with you on on on
this as these major spiritual and
esoteric teachings talk about these
moments I want to say that it seems like
um you did in your book quite a bit and
I know David Icke is right now doing
this quite a bit as well my my thing is
that um I think that's like science it
done
spiritually ethically morally
philosophically aware and advanced can
do things like take your child that is
about to get some sort of like a
single-point genetic mutation and
they're gonna have Down syndrome or some
sort of an ailment in their life and we
can be smart enough to eradicate that
and so I think that of course with
things like 5g you should just have this
fake race idea economically and and and
put it out there without having these
longitudinal tests over five years ten
years on and we already saw some on on
mouse studies and what and what has
happened so I do think the idea of like
slow down spiritually advanced
yourselves then release technologies is
very important but I I don't necessarily
can't I can't really blanket say that
it's all um only bad and I just want to
hear what you think about the
possibility of evolving aware enough to
make these technologies in a way that
actually serves the evolution of
consciousness rather than traps us
that matrix control system through the
brain computer interfaces and stuff like
that yeah yeah now absolutely I mean
when you look more into the nature of
these forces that run this control
system you're real you realize that
being cut off from the I guess the
original greats very creative force they
don't have any ability to create they
don't have any creative imagination so
what they do what they tend to do is
hire exploit the human in create the
incredible human ability for creativity
and imagination
so especially within their institutions
they will get people into them that
create all these amazing technologies
cradle these things that can connect
humanity more than ever before and can
actually be used for amazing purposes
but then they hijack them and subvert
them into technologies that they can
then use to control I mean five degree I
don't have any problem with an extra
more bandwidth internet that connects us
faster and allows us to do more
incredible things but there's no reason
it can't be rolled out through
fiber-optic cables for example and have
the benefits of it but without the the
radiation that the towers are going to
be fruiting off but that weren't
untested millimeter reading intestine
yeah but but it's because and you know I
don't I don't necessarily have a problem
with smart devices that are smart and I
guess make our lives more easier on a
day to day basis so that we have to do
less laborious mundane things and we can
focus more in creative outlets but so
these are things that I believe humans
have created because of our ingenuity
and our creative abilities but then a
hijacked by these forces who manipulate
them to serve their own agenda which is
all about control and all about
centralization of power so rather than
using five clear in these smart devices
and all these other things to help
improve our lives they want to use it
through centralized power and so the
more we can become savvy about that and
not throw the baby out
the bathwater because technology has
made life a lot better but when we're
not aware of these forces who want to
exploit it for their own purposes we're
just going to keep blindly stepping into
the kind of trap that perhaps at their
setting and and but the thing is that go
back at the point you said earlier the
more that they the more that they try to
push this control system out the more in
our faces it's becoming the more and
more people who the more and more people
are waking up and the more people are
stopping in actually asking the
questions what what is going on in our
world and that's where we're at right
now I believe where a lot of people are
finally at that point where the spell
that's been put over them for so long is
starting to break and they're actually
going what what is going on there's
something going on and that's that's
where people need to be and in terms of
whether enough people wake up fast
enough to to move this in another
direction or move these top technologies
in a direction that actually serve
humanity rather than control us it's
it's hard to say it's it's it's kind of
coming down to the wire a little bit and
yeah I'm will tell and all we can keep
doing is what you're doing is is doing
your absolute best to get information
out there and give people the best
chance they can to have to make informed
decisions and giving people practical
advice on how to develop themselves and
that's all we we can really do and and I
want to also say that I think that
specifically entrepreneurship is such a
massive catalyst of the heart of the
world that our hearts know is possible
because if we continue on the comments
section is kind of like all that I like
Munir in your book ready you can give
this example it's the sazhin water
filter right and I looked them up and
they're very interesting company with
this 10 stage water filtration process
and the idea is that like if you
yourself believe and if other people
believe that their water supply
as fluoride and other chemicals that are
harmful to their health in it first of
all you know become a scientist and
begin testing your water and and begin
documenting it putting the videos up on
YouTube sharing that step to you know go
to the UM go to your spring like you do
your local spring and get water or get
the water filter in like through zossen
but what happened was the guy the geyser
girls the entrepreneurs at Zossen
decided enough is enough we are going to
make our own water filter we are going
to become entrepreneurs we are gonna
start selling this to people and that's
an example I think of of of people um
building the future of of light that
they want rather than too dark and I
think the same thing is true with um all
of the genetic engineering brain
computer interfaces 5 G's blah blahs all
of those things they are VRS that are
happening even cryptocurrencies the idea
of of a fully decentralized digital
currency it sounds incredible but again
it's important like are the people that
are at the center of that um truly
spiritually awakened to the complete
decentralization of it where you and I
are still not being tracked in some sort
of a way whereas cash has way less of a
ability to be tracked so I think it's
such a entrepreneurs can and will save
the world if we really give them the
resources to artistically express
themselves to make that light world that
we know is possible how do you feel how
do you feel about that yeah absolutely
like every every issue I see popping up
in the world whether it be fluoride in
the water or whether it be the radiation
from 5g towers or so many other things
that people are concerned about there's
also entrepreneurs creating incredible
solutions for it I mean I'm already
hearing about fire fire radiation
blocking clothing that's that's been
developed there's people I know I know
of I know of one person obviously it
requires a bit of money to do this but
he's built he built his house with a
Faraday cage like
structure within the whole house so the
whole house is like a 5g blocking house
and there's other people who are
painting their walls with orgonite
crushed-up orgonite stone in the paint
that is a 5 d blocker and so there's
there's incredible solutions to a lot of
the problems that we face but as you
said we just need to support these
people who are doing it and and it does
it comes from entrepreneurialism people
people people come in from their own
place of creativity and problem-solving
and that is definitely what this control
system wants to stamp out it wants all
of the creative output an energy of
humanity to be controlled by these
massive multinational corporations so
that the most brilliant scientists the
most brilliant engineers the most
brilliant developers and technicians and
philosophers and thinkers are being
controlled and contained within these
corporations and corporations and have
to are being forced to sing from the
same song sheet and are being often
often they're intimidated into doing so
because you know they're intimidated
through having their reputation
slandered or their intimidate by having
their funds taken away or maybe their
family is threatened or they're
threatened and so there's all sorts of
ways the system will try to intimidate
the brilliant the most brilliant
thinkers and developers of humanity into
being in line with the with the
mainstream consensus and and that's why
it comes down through both the
entrepreneurs tapping into their own
inner courage to overcome that and not
let that stop them from doing what they
believe is the right thing to do but
then on the other hand us as people
supporting them as well you know and
share it sharing their information and
looking more into what they're doing and
buying their products that we believe in
because the amount of people out there
finding solutions is just endless and
and it's really what this if there is
any going to be a revolution I believe
it's going to be a grassroots one that's
built from person to person
yeah I I'm so happy that that that
resonated with you like that it's gonna
be yeah that's that's gonna be a crucial
part of us moving forward into the
lightest is supporting the UM creative
entrepreneurial creation since that
space um a bunch of other thoughts that
I want to list out from what you wrote
and then I'll um hear your thoughts on
it so I'm a lot of what we were talking
about is people waking up in this matrix
control system um have believed that um
one of these most pivotal er
instrumental events that occurred on the
way was the assassination of JFK in 1963
who was trying to blow the lid on the
Cabal control unit cult and that one of
the most common things that people like
Eric Weinstein has been talking about
which is very interesting is this idea
that the purchasing power has been just
dropped down the toilet we had um you
know Tim Blake on our show recently
who's also talked about this where he in
1970 was super able to and he all his
friends were super able to on just one
um father the male in the family working
on once on one salary was able to
support the wife the mother to stay at
home raised the two children they were
able to have a house plus another house
in the woods plus a boat at that like
lake house on one salary now both
parents are working and they can barely
make ends meet for even one um property
and the general idea and I can I can put
in right here the the chart here the the
GDP since 1970 has just been
continuously going up meanwhile median
male income has just been flatlining and
where is all of the wealth is going to
the concentrated 1% of people and so um
you gave these examples the government
has been responsible for over 200
million deaths in the last 100 years
which is insane to think about and you
can think about Stalin lining the gulag
you can think about Mao you can think
about Pol Pot Hitler you can think about
all these types of people over the last
hundred years
I want to touch on this the idea that
it's it's possible that a future where
if you look so far out this is kind of
what I like doing as well I like
thinking about things like what is
possible with future technologies that
are so advanced like what happens when
we get beyond the speed of light is this
actually a physical constraint what
happens when we unlock our own source
code of this reality and understand it
at that most fundamental physical level
can we have warp drives Star Trek can we
have replicators that do the mass energy
equivalence equals mc-squared and can
turn energy into mass into food and then
is that the obsolete men of money
transporters for moving from one place
to another like like that so um I I
really really really just adore the idea
of both exposing the dark and helping
people awaken to that like you do and
also empowering the light and having
some sort of a goal right this big
picture goal in computer science is
called the Monte Carlo tree search that
you go and you find something at the end
of this tree branch like a fruit and you
say that that's the fruit that I want to
work towards or that's the fruit that
the collective wants to work towards and
that then you get all these
entrepreneurial creative solutions going
going towards that so in in a sense is
this big merging of science and
spirituality we have now for the longest
time had ancient spiritual texts that
you that we talked about the beginning
and that you listened your books that
have been talking about what is they got
what's God was about what is Brahman
what is all that is our source and now
science had coming up with quantum
theory also similarly this universal
wavefunction this many worlds
understanding parallel universes
multiverse the idea that that
consciousness is so inextricably
intertwined with matter and with our
life outcome
that revealed in the double split
experiment which we've had several shows
on and I'm glad that you brought that up
as well it does feel like the more that
we live in unity consciousness and the
more that we ground that here and embody
that into matter the more we can create
the divine life on earth the less we can
be under the forces of the matrix
control system and the Cabal and the
negative occult entities and that this
is just the most beautiful possible
thing imaginable is literally this
reality and that we are in a state of
constant exploration evolving and that
this is just a beautiful nature of
reality and let's hear your thoughts on
kind of what I've said your closing
thoughts and then we can wrap because
this is this has been so awesome that
I'm pumped yeah let me know what do you
think yeah I mean it is really important
to be I guess using the power of
imagination to ponder on the sort of
world that we want to bring about and
because you know without going into like
the new the New Age is kind of
manipulated that whole reality creation
concerts but I do believe that we we do
create our mind is very powerful and we
do I have a big influence on on the way
reality works through our beliefs and
our perceptions and I think that that's
also another thing that's hijacked by
the control system which is why they
pummel our minds with an endless array
of dystopian dark movies and TV shows
that shows a future dystopian world with
confront like a totalitarian control
system and because that's the world they
want to bring about as the world they
want to pummel into our minds so that we
help actually create that as well so we
sort of subconsciously just think it's
inevitable
so I recommend kind of staying away from
those sort of things as much as possible
not especially
you know
controlling what information reaches
your mind being discerning with what TV
shows what movies you watch and you know
especially things like the mainstream
media that's obviously a given
mainstream yeah
lame stream media sorry but in terms of
like in terms of imagining the exact
world that we want to bring about a
world that's based on you know a deeper
spiritual connection and purpose and
values of truth and connection and
service to others how that looks on the
database it is it can be challenging to
actually envision there's actually one
I'm not sure if you've heard of a guy
named Michael challenger yeah yeah you
booed - yeah yeah he's so good yeah
you're right you ready yeah brother yeah
I brought I bring that up now because in
terms of explaining that kind of what
you call a utopian world or something
like that he doesn't actually he's
actually done an incredible job so he's
proposed this entirely new system called
that he calls a boon - that's based on
not based on an economical model at all
it's based on what he calls contribution
ISM and in his book abun - the way he
outlines it and the world he describes
that he envisions coming about I I just
really recommend people reading that
just to get that image in their minds
like it's true through many details for
me to explain here but it's I remember
reading up being like oh my god I've
never even thought of world like this is
impossible and I'm so glad that that
possibility is just planted in my mind
now
now I'm always cautious about saying go
follow movements like that because
unless the people in those sort of
movements are grounded in sincere self
work are grounded in shadow work are
focused on their own inner journey
rather than just purely astana kernel
changes they're trying to make I can
guarantee that there will be forces that
will divide and divide that group within
and conquer it and subvert its it
subvert it to another agenda so I don't
think any any movements any things are
gonna work unless everyone involved is
is involved in insincere
al-farouq and shadow work so that their
their blind spots copy and manipulated
and exploited by forces that are so good
at that so that's why I always keep
coming back to the inner journey but in
terms of actually envisioning a world
like you said that that Ubuntu removed
and I believe it's got a really really
fantastic vision that I highly recommend
reading his book or is he's got a he
outlines and also in a series on
guide.com that is really really good if
you're a bit more of a visual person
contribution some of them the The Venus
Project is also another very interesting
one yeah that's another that's another
really good one yet yeah absolutely
you also mention earthships on your in
your book yeah yes or I'm really that's
another thing like you know the more
that these issues keep coming about in
our world and one one issue is that so
the more the solutions keep popping up
and one of the biggest issues I've seen
pop up in especially in the last 50 or
100 years is our complete utter
dependence on multinational corporations
for our resources so we now depend
completely on corporations for our
energy for our food for our shelter all
the basics of basically human living
that in a past time would have been up
to our own kind of independence to
acquire and there's there's good and bad
so that the good the good is that it's
comfortable and that we don't have to
build all our and things and put out all
our daily energy into into survival but
the downside is is the centralization of
control that has come about with that
and so these this concept has been
developed by this guy named Michael
Reynolds over in America and he's
developed these things called Earth
ships which basically these houses
developed from there created but from
fully recycled ingredients and they once
you're in it that they're completely
disconnected from the grid once you're
in it they produce their own energy
their own food their own water just the
most ingenious design I elaborate them
on in the book and these are the things
we need to be looking into and and and
supporting as much as we can so that's
sort of a world I envision
is a world based on true sustainability
not there not the sustainability that's
been hijacked by the kind of climate
change movement that's that's not really
about sustained really that's about
centralization of control I'm talking
sustainability where each person is
given through things like earthships and
through things like teaching about
permaculture and growing their own food
and and capturing their own like getting
their own fresh water supply gives gives
us fruit independence and autonomy in
our lives and these things as I said
they're already being developed we just
need to support them they're not going
to be presented to us on the Main Street
on the lamestream nightly news they're
not going to be on the front page of the
newspaper in fact the amount of
resistance Mike Reynolds and his team
has got from councils and governments in
terms of trying to stop him doing what
he's doing which was just developing
off-grid sustainable houses has been
mind-boggling and a clear attempt to
stop his progress but so he's been
relentless so I love seeing people like
him and Michael challenger of Ubuntu and
all these other unbelievable
entrepreneurs who are providing us with
solutions they may not be perfect they
may need tweaks they may need
adjustments but they're there they're
there they're right in front of us and I
think those solutions are always going
to keep popping up all we need to do is
keep doing the self work in our daily
lives so that we have the courage to
make the changes in our lives that we
need to make and then that will that'll
inspire our families inspire the people
around us and that creates this kind of
ripple effect throughout humanity but it
a cake keeps I keep trying to whatever
whenever I'm talking about these things
I always try to bring the message back
to self responsibility because it's so
easy for us to for people to get so
fixated on the external fixes they
forget the responsibility they have in
that equation and and so what happens is
we're either if we're if we're so
focused on the external were either
waiting for saviors and waiting for
people to come save us or when that
doesn't happen we just instantly fall
into victim mode but when we when
everything we do is based on self
responsibility it's really nice when
extern
solutions come along but we're not
relying on it we're not dependent on it
and it and it can be challenging when
stuff comes along that that that is is
basically sends our life in a turmoil
like this current covert knighting
crisis but we don't fall into victimhood
because of it we just keep moving
forward with what we know is is is well
where need to do in our day-to-day life
so I hope I hope that answers that okay
yeah yeah I have two questions that I
like asking on the way out to our guests
would you say that this is a simulation
of source would you say this reality is
a simulation of source yeah I mean
there's a lot of things pointing towards
that isn't there like you can you can
imagine this human body is like a
virtual reality suit for spirit and I've
tried I've tried virtual reality before
for the first time a year ago and and
went into a simulated world and all I
had on was goggles and earplugs and
gloves and so I didn't I wasn't didn't
have every one of my bodily senses
hijacks just those main ones and I was
fully in another world yes I was so in
that world it was so believable when
things came at me it felt real so the
idea that that's already happened to a
degree I'm very open to that possibility
that the human body in a lot of ways
feels like a virtual reality suit yeah
yeah so that's a great way to put it and
then this second question is what do you
think is most beautiful
who
that down just you just talking about in
life or just just anything anything what
is most beautiful to you I for me
the thing that I always this I mean or
and and inspire by is the human spirit I
just think the human spirit outside
genetic psychopaths that is the the the
human spirit when especially when we're
not in a state of stress and
fight/flight and activated reptilian
brain which certainly doesn't bring out
the best part of ourselves but when when
when you see the true human spirit it is
it is just so like it kind of like makes
my eyes well I feel a little bit it's
just like so so much love and care in it
and so much we just want to be connected
with people and we want to help people
and we want to create and we want to
experience life and I see I'm always on
the lookout for that human spirit coming
about out of people you know comes out
it comes out in times of crisis it comes
out in the most unexpected times I
sometimes love going you know I've been
to a number of music festivals and my
main motivation those I love seeing
people away from civilization camping
and you just see that true essence come
out and it's so it's really so beautiful
so that if I had to choose one thing I'd
say I think that is it yeah it's
beautiful and that and that's all that's
often that's actually what motivates me
a lot as well is I this think that this
human speed this the human family is
something worth really fighting for like
I think wearing I think we're incredible
we are we're totally programmed to think
the opposite of out of ourselves were
programmed to be feel disempowered and
that we're pointless like like
mainstream science basically tells us
we're random where we just we're random
bunches of cells that have come together
and where random lumps of flesh and when
we die that's it and we're we're all
separate from each other and we're here
just to toil and labor and there's no
higher purpose and it's it's very
disempowering but the more you
Challenge that and look into who's
telling us that and why they're telling
is the more you realize what they're
covering up the truth is extremely
empowering and it's like wow we're
actually here for a really important
purpose we're really amazing and we're
with our potential is just ridiculous so
that's that that's sort of those beliefs
fill me with a lot of energy and the
more I learned about the huge the true
human spirit the more I want to really
fight for it I love this is an epic show
yeah and I thank you so much I yeah I I
we as I said at the beginning we really
went deep fast and I love that and sort
of kept maintain the same level of depth
all the way through no no easy and it
was like and I thought I I loved it like
as you know from the book that's the
book is yes diving into anything and
everything and and I love talking about
these things that fills me with energy
and I love what you're doing and really
appreciate you know you're taking the
time to have me on and also reading the
book it really means a lot yeah you did
a really good job piecing together this
is yeah this is again what we were
talking about these entrepreneurs these
artists these spiritual leaders can can
we eat can we really architect that
social fabric that inspires people to
want to actualize their gifts like you
did where you took this time to put
together some beautiful artistic
expression that then is going to go
resonate with so many people in that
resonated with me so much that I had to
do read in one day and then and then
interview you afterwards so um I I've
loved this this has been awesome
everyone again Matt's website seeds of
awareness dot-com dot a you that link
isn't a bio below you can find his book
free range humans exposing the matrix
control system and awakening your true
self on the website as well also his
other book is there as well 365 days of
wholeness and he has a range of other
materials as well under its the
resources tab right is where you have a
bunch of these materials
yep I'm Azeri resources section with a
whole lot of different topics ranging
from esotericism spirituality to the New
World Order agenda to science to
personal development and just all the
main resources that have that have had
probably the biggest impact on me over
the last 10 years listed there so
definitely check that out
exactly and that is that is all do
support Matt support your other people
in your communities and your other
friends that are artists that are
entrepreneurs that are spiritual leaders
support them help them flourish you can
support our show all of our links are in
the bio below where you can support us
and that is all go and build the future
of room and manifest your dreams into
the world get to that unity
consciousness ground that embody it in
the physical reality we love you very
much we'll talk to you soon
peace
[Music]